[Applaudissements]
canton de publie la musique oui voilà
donc à chaque fois vous attendrez un la
musique qu'il ya aujourd'hui il a choisi
balla balla balla et les délais et les
qui veut dire c'est par là par la pala
parler parler parler vrai c'est en fait
un gars qui cherche sa route il est
complètement perdu le gars et voilà et
il est dans la merde on va pas se mentir
voilà il en a fait une chanson on va
accueillir tout de suite nos deux
invités mais juste avant juste avant il
ya une personne qui a été désigné pour
être en a dit c'était l'eau dit mot sur
un grill a décidé puisqu'elle a gagné
pour la deuxième fois d'affilée le
taulier du post c'est christophe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était quoi ça va mal elle n'est pas
moi ça légumes oui garder le jeu pour
toi que j'ai poussé 26 je suis désolé si
l'on tire vraiment à l'heure
d'accueillir nos deux invités du soir
evelyne thomas jolly
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]